[Musique]
il paraît qu'on voit tous une fois dans
ce métier je crois qu'on n'a jamais vu
ça
[Musique]
tout va bien
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'on ne peut
pas opérer comme ce vendredi
qu'est ce qui se passe mais qu
je veux être sûr de donner du sens à
tout ce que je fais
si vous regardez ça c'est soit que je
suis en train de vous convaincre de
quelque chose qui est assez dur à croire
soir au caire
vraiment n'importe quoi qu'elle revienne
mais là c'est la prochaine dose pourrait
tuer tout certaines choses sont qu'à
pire que tout
qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé il n'en fit
pas
c'est moi qui dois y est tu acceptes pas
na waie
le sablier n'arrête pas de s'écouler
le temps est une édition
[Musique]